what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting back into the
flash rebirth it's part of DC rebirth
and again this is cool you know honestly
it's been a little while since we've
covered the flash and it is it is one of
my favorite stories just in terms of how
it's how it's being written now I
remember in the last video that we did
it was really like the negative
storyline and that was about as close as
Barry Allen ever got to like becoming
the reverse-flash now ultimately you'd
basically reverted back to his normal
self but it was pretty cool because what
this did is a set the money I'll set him
on this collision course where his life
was effectively out of control now this
idea of like acting out in the various
forms of behavior that came with him
being basically negative flash resulted
in him being pushed out basically from
the central city crime lab and being
forced to work in iron Heights
penitentiary now there are worse places
to be besides iron Heights but it is
kind of a crappy place to be because
it's basically Barry Allen being forced
to face all the various criminals that
he'd arrested over the course of his
life but as soon as he gets in there
he's immediately met with what's
basically a murder regarding a guy named
turbine now turbine was at one point
kind of a villain he was he wasn't
really like a huge villain um and really
like the Rogues of Barry Allen aren't
necessarily like huge villains turbine
was basically a Tuskegee Airmen who
fought during World War two ended up
stuck in the feed Speed Force came out
and then just became a bad guy he was
kind of a ro kind of not a rogue he was
on again off again but he was for the
most part of villain of baryons now the
other half of this is that iron Heights
itself is currently under the control of
a guy named Gregory wolf now Gregory
wolf is a character who made his debut
back in the flash iron Heights and he
was created by Geoff Johns and Ethan Van
Sciver the general idea of him was that
he just hated inmates oh he hated
everybody in iron Heights and he would
make their lives as miserable as humanly
possible
now the indication here is that Joshua
Williamson is kind of going the same way
but there's also this undercurrent that
like something else is going on now
again there really is no love loss here
between Singh and between Gregory Wolfe
so there's kind of like you know
whatever you know these guys you know
Barry Allen and them are here not to
investigate your crime scene they're
here to just preserve the crime scene
and that's really about it but then
suddenly they're met with your rival of
trickster now XO Walker is kind of a
funny character right like he's like a
more toned down version of the Joker the
tricks are showing up here and just kind
of acting bonkers and being silly is
it's kind of like
I'm the one who killed her bond it's my
responsibility you know I basically just
kind of taking the route after what
she's essentially sent off to solitary
confinement now from here we go through
and we basically have Barry Allen just
kind of stumbling across Godspeed
now get autist hard is probably one of
the coolest villains that Barry Allen's
face off against not just because of the
fact that he got his powers during a
Speed Force storms he genuinely believed
he was right like going through and
killing villains to his utilitarianism
but there is no love loss you remember
Barry Allen does not like God speed
because God speeds willing to do the
things that Barry Allen's not he's
willing to get his hands dirty and
actually fight the good fight and so if
the result is that Barry just kind of
doesn't like him too much and ultimately
the sort of storms off now from here we
pick up with a really funny moment here
what you have are basically the trigger
twins now the trigger twins are not very
important here I mean they aren't
interesting because basically they show
up and rob a bank at the same time as
being robbed by somebody else but the
trigger twins are kind of cool they were
throwback to the Old West characters
that can all I want to say all-star
Western 18 way back in the day and
they're basically just like twin
brothers who were separated at birth and
became armed robbers and just by
happenstance met up with each other and
just kind of became like a team of armed
robbers but again this kind of puts on
the idea that there are various
criminals out there especially like
Copperhead who were basically vying for
their own schemes and their own
organizations and this is when we find
out that what's going on inside iron
Heights
is a little more complex than we
originally thought where the warden
checks in on who's where and who's doing
what and making sure everybody's in
checked we end up finding out that like
Captain Cold is actually not in his cell
that is basically a hologram instead he
alongside the other rogues have actually
orchestrated this massive criminal
underworld up below iron Heights they're
literally operating under the nose of
Gregory Wolfe and so what is up
happening here is we have August Hart
who shows up on the doorstep of the
roads and basically says look I want to
join your ranks and I can give you the
flash which is actually kind of cool
because to see him becoming a member of
the Rogues raises a couple eyebrows in
terms of what direction things could
take we've never really seen a speedster
as part of the Rogues before and that's
always really been like the shortcomings
of the group while they have been
interesting and they haven't able to
hold their own against barry allen
having a member of the world having a
speedster join their ranks for any real
measure of time which is the indication
that's being given off here could
actually change the landscape in a lot
of different ways and make the group a
lot more dangerous than they were before
the problem with this is that where
Barry and
teamate I guess Kristen are kind of
going through and trying to figure out
what they should do in terms of
investigating the death of turbines or
so on and so forth they are basically
defying orders they're doing what they
naturally do which is solve crimes and
so once they stumble across a solitary
confinement cell of actual of Trixter
they end up finding out that one is arm
was removed and two like he's had that
crop beat out of him by the guards and
the implication is that like Gregory
Wolfe is having the prisoners abuse now
this is where you know Barry Allen
begins to sort of realize Sonny
nefarious is going on behind the scenes
and that's where Joshua Williams said he
grabs a character as you know grabs
Wolfe as the existing DC rebirth and
brings him closer in line with his
classic depiction of having an absolute
hatred of the inmate and that's what and
that's what trickster hits on here that
the reason why you're at least as far as
we're aware the reason why turbine was
killed is because he had found
Redemption he basically found remorse
for the things that he'd done and he was
turning over a new leaf he was gonna go
state witness he was gonna basically
testify against the ropes and the result
was that trickster steps up and says I
killed him because he was gonna rat us
all out so it's pretty intense and it's
pretty extreme only for their interview
to suddenly be interrupted by Gregory
Wolfe who says look you guys gotta get
out of here you guys gotta go now at
this point August Hart steps in passes a
piece of information to Barry and
basically walks away but Barry of
Barry's immediate reaction to this is
there's no possible way this is like a
coincidence this is him basically giving
me evidence but he's terrible at it now
again this fits in with the character of
god speed the way he's been developed by
Joshua Williams Cedric god speed was a
detective he was a cop before he became
basically an anti hero or villain
depending on how you're looking at it
and he was never cooking he was never on
the take right as long like he was a
crooked cop who suddenly gained the
powers of the Speed Force and just
wanted to start killing villains
it was the idea that like he was a cop
they genuinely thought he was doing the
right thing stopping criminals before
they can commit further actions of
violence but because of the fact that he
was never on the take he was never one
to be able to plant evidence and so
where he shows up to Barry and basically
instead of just kind of sliding him a
piece of information basically like
draws out this huge scenario Barry
Allen's immediate response is this guy's
basically trying his best to give me
some info and kind of not doing too well
at it but you know I've got the info I
need and we'll call it a day and so what
is up happening is it got to be the past
Barry the location of where the Rogues
were operating out of and where a
meeting was supposed to be going down
between Copperhead her forces and
presumably whatever the Rogues were
dealing now in Barry
and and younger Wally West I guess you
know new 52 Wally West show up on the
scene a couple of things begin to catch
their eye the first is that the weapons
that are being traded are weapons that
use the technology that Captain Cold
uses and because snart is the only
person who's really able to create
weapons like this in this same way he's
the expert on it the immediate
indication is that like the robes are
the ones that are doing this the Rogues
that are the ones who were running the
show here and they've somehow managed to
find a way to run a criminal enterprise
outside of iron Heights at the same time
you end up having like Copperhead who
basically takes off or at least you
don't one of the guys who takes off
Barry ends up having to run directly to
the location of where the Rogues are
operating out of and so him a new 52
Wally West's basically split Wally takes
off after the resources and Barry goes
after wherever the rugs are operating
out of only for him to stumble across
and realize this is a trap that's been
set up by auguste heart and the rope and
this is cool this is what I like about
this is because you never know what
direction August heart is gonna go in is
he a good guy is he a bad guy it's one
of those things were it's like he's just
kind of whatever he wants to be at any
point in time this is one of the reasons
why I would say that we're I still have
a special place in my heart for for
eobard thawne weary aboard Thawne is
still my favorite villain of the flash
God speed is rapidly getting up there
because he's so cool the way that he's
renting now the other part here is that
in this environment that Barry's in is
basically been modified using the
technology of Captain Cold to reduce the
temperature of the space which slows him
down but also gives an advantage of
Captain Cold who decides he wants to
beat the crap out of Barry Allen
presumably beat him to death now the
funny thing here is that almost
immediately after this fight ensues then
like suddenly you have August heart god
speed who runs in deactivates the
Machine and allows Barry Allen to get
the upper hand on on Captain Cold and
basically start to take out the roads so
that's why things are so cool is because
like he's a bad guy that he's a good guy
that he's a bad guy again and then he's
a good guy again and it's like okay so
like I love this back and forth I love
him like switching this position up time
and time again and that's what August
heart comes clean and he says look I'm
trying to be a good guy here i
infiltrated the Rogues so I could figure
out what their plan was I passed you
that information so you would show up
here and then I basically put this ruse
on so they would believe me to be one of
their own and when the time came I
basically gave you the keys to the city
I'm on your side and so we're real Barry
Allen is kind of stuck in this weird
situation because what he starts to
realize is that these weapons that have
been used by Captain Cold it was a setup
the idea was to take out copperheads
remove her from the landscape and just
kind of
leave the field open for caffeine code
to run is like the head of this criminal
enterprise inside of Central City
and when Barry Allen starts to realize
that he realizes new 52 flash is
probably gonna die
because he doesn't know what's going on
and so God speed gives Barry a choice
either you can deal with me or you can
take off after Kid Flash let me do my
job and let me basically reveal all this
stuff - Gregory wolf so that he can
essentially know what's going on in the
very least you know we could let him do
his job or whatever it is it needs to be
done and so because of this Barry takes
off after movie - Wally West and as soon
as he gets there the bombs go off
basically everything starts freezing up
Barry rescues them in the nick of time
but here's the funny thing about this
and this this is what I love the DC
Universe in a lot of ways when it comes
to how superheroes relate to things for
the most part in Marvel you don't really
see legal ramifications for things you
do to a degree but it's usually only
ever because of like what the
superheroes choose to do for example
Captain America says like we're gonna do
this because it's the right thing to do
not because we have to really worry
about anybody but because it's just the
right thing to do but here like Barry
Allen is ultimately forced to let
copperhead go because she's got an
airtight alibi as far as the world of
the world is concerned as far as the
circumstances are concerned she was just
an innocent bystander there's no
witnesses except for nudity flash and
Barry Allen but there's no like physical
evidence like video evidence or anything
like that
linking her to this crime and so she's
essentially bled off but ultimately we
end up finding out Lynyrd snart is the
one who basically killed killed turbine
just because of the fact that Barry
analyzed the the corpse one last time or
at least had Singh and his guys analyzed
the corpse one last time and found cold
residue around his neck the implication
being that Captain cold was the one who
killed turbine kavanah cold kind of
freaks out says look turbine was gonna
betray us and I did what I had to do and
so ultimately we're Gregory Wolfe says
hey look fine we'll take care of him
we'll put him in a Cell and make sure he
doesn't get away Singh actually has a
better idea and ultimately has Captain
Cold handed over directly to the Suicide
Squad where he just ends up working for
Amanda Waller at the same time what you
also have is you know Barry's partner
Kristen basically getting an in with
Gregory Wolfe where Singh comes down and
says look I have to report you for this
like you had a syndicate operating under
your nose as a warden this just shows a
neglect in the extreme you're derelict
in your duties as a warden ultimately if
she steps in and says no no everybody
makes mistakes the ropes have tricked
Barry out or they took the flash before
no one's perfect here but by standing up
for the warden she's earned an inch
she's basically earned the confidence of
the war
and this was the plan the entire time
Singh had basically sent her in as a
mole and to say look your job is to
infiltrate the prison and your job is to
gain the trust of the warden so we can
figure out what's going on behind the
scenes when you're in let me know that's
the purpose of her being there for Barry
himself he's found some measure of
redemption I mean August Hart found
Redemption as well like that was the
whole point was to say look I'm trying
to be a good guy here I'm trying to make
up for my past misdeeds I realized that
just killing villains in order to save
innocent lives for whatever reason is
not the best decision to make like
sacrificing innocent people is cool you
know because villains deserve a second
chance and because of that I'm trying to
correct my ways and so with Barry Allen
seeing this kind of redemption through
August Hart in turn he shows up on the
doorstep we're really kind of it is at
the cemetery of his mother Nora Allen
and says look like it's so easy for me
to become the reverse-flash it would be
so easy for me to just like fall down
the rabbit hole and become eobard thawne
to do what what you know I'm sorry what
August Hart did the entire time yeah
we're August Hart believe in killing
criminals to stop them from killing
innocent people I could do that too but
the difference between myself and God
speed and reverse-flash in these various
villains that I faced are the decisions
that we make the fact that I believe bad
guys can become good people they can do
good things but in order to find
forgiveness you have to seek it out you
can't wait for word to come to you and
that's why he basically shows up and
asks for forgiveness of iris West
basically ask your forgiveness for the
betrayal ask for forgiveness of the way
he treated her when he was negative the
kind of rift he created between the two
of them all these different things
looking to finally get her back to his
side kind of Joshua Williamson hitting
it the idea that like they're back on
the road of redemption and maybe the
time will come when Barry Allen and iris
West will finally get together but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]